equivalent and simplified fraction okay
now underneath you I'd like you to draw
a little diagram for me okay
um how should we make it yeah okay draw
for me a little square that's are
divided up into four rows and four
columns like this
four rows and four columns
okay draw that alright now this is what
I used to illustrate the fact that when
we talk about fractions right there's
lots of different ways to say the same
thing not just fractions and percentages
and decimals but even different
fractions that mean the same thing they
are equivalent okay now there's your
little box there okay I want you shade
half of it for me like so if you have
another card that would be helpful and
probably make it a little computer okay
now hopefully you joining us a little
more accurately than mine and your
sixteen squares are all about the same
size okay now I ask you to shade half of
it right a half okay but how many
squares did you shade like the little
squares
hmm there are eight right are two four
six eight so that means this fraction is
the same as eight out of how many little
squares are there in total you said 60
all right okay all right the other one
so you can see here right how do I get
this the numerator in the denominator if
I multiply them by the same number
multiplied by eight on the top and eight
on the bottom they're all same okay so
you can see they're kind of I can
multiply by any number I like so long as
I do it to the top and the bottom and
these fractions are going to be the same
they'll all be equivalent so give me a
number
you just another not to me so that I can
do in my head hey I'm just going to do
five I do I can't I can't do 56 in my
head of what today eight times five you
guys made your times tables that's funny
buddy isn't it
forty okay sixteen times five that's a
and just as you'd expect 40 over eighty
would be still like so that'll be
dividing up these squares into smaller
pieces but it's still the same fraction
okay so all of these they're all I don't
do this like minds like information
practice these are all equivalent
fractions they're all equivalent but one
and only one of these factions is the
simplified fraction the simplest one or
reduced to its simplest form which one
is it
yeah it's one over two now or what makes
that one what makes 1/2 1 over 2 what
makes it the sin fost
1 over 2 I can't make these numbers any
smaller
40 over 80 I can reduce those stuff the
same fraction 8 over 16 I can keep going
whatever to though I can't they're a
nice whole number smaller than one other
so I'm kind of stuck this is as far as I
can go
this guy here is the simplest or a
simplified fraction